[Music]
the the pilot project is quite modest so
before we go out and build huge floating
structures for hundreds and thousands of
people we're building a small pilot
which will be about the size if you can
imagine a soccer field around 7,500
square meters the engineers are saying
it shouldn't be a single platform it
should be multiple smaller platforms so
maybe 12 platforms of 625 so about 625
square meters so imagine a platform 25
meters by 25 meters next to another one
with connecting bridges and the reason
for smaller structures is that we're
going to be inside the reef within a
lagoon of an island and what you don't
want is to cast a shadow on the bottom
of of the lagoon that will obviously
impact photosynthesis which means we'll
have a problem with with the environment
so we need smaller platforms in order
for light to penetrate and we need deep
lagoons so we had to literally do an
inventory of all of the depths of the
lagoon around the main islands we're
interested in we found certain lagoons
and the engineers are telling us
environmental consultants are saying
that between 25 to 30 meters of depth we
will be very we won't have an impact on
on the light situation so that's that's
one of the elements of location now in
terms of size because it's a pilot we
don't anticipate being able to be
completely self-sustaining on food we
can be completely autonomous on on
energy on fresh water completely recycle
our grey and black water do all of that
and deal with our trash what we're not
going to be able to do on the pilot is
be a hundred percent self-sustaining for
food but we do have a food group that
that's involved in trying to look at
these technologies and what we could do
and we're looking at all sorts of stuff
I mean there's one thing that kind of
came out of a laboratory in Hawaii from
from nailhead the National Energy
Laboratory in Hawaii they call it cold
egg cold agriculture what it is is you
put a pipe a small pipe maybe 500 to 900
meters deep you bring in
cold deep ocean water so it's similar to
the seawater air-conditioning systems
there's been two of them for the first
two have been put into resorts in French
Polynesia so those are installed and
working the difference here is that you
run the cold water through copper pipes
so small little capillaries that you
bury under soil so the air in inference
barney's is very humid and warmer so
when that warm air warm moist air hits
these tiny capillaries even under the
ground what happens is obviously you get
condensation and moisture around those
tubes and what you do then is you plant
cold weather plants you know fruits
vegetables strawberries raspberries and
the roots actually will go down to these
tubes and they'll pick up the moisture
so you've got a system that uses very
little energy to create fresh water for
your agriculture and it seems that the
vegetables are tricked by the
temperature at the roots and not the
temperature at the leaves so you
basically get the sunlight from tropical
environment but you get the cold the
fruit you know the strawberry thinks
it's in Maine but suddenly it's
producing very quickly so this this is
not new technology this has been tested
at NOAA for many years it's one of the
technologies we're looking at to have
some vegetables on the sea stat itself
we're looking at algae there's a number
of comestibles algae out there I'm not
the expert on our team but we do have a
full team of food experts are trying to
see what we're going to be eating on on
board
the sea stead we are not going to be
bringing cows and you know cattle on
onto the platform it's very expensive in
terms of real estate so there's all
sorts of strategies about what exactly
could wheat as alternatives to meat is
it lab-grown mate that was a huge leap
in technology that's that's fairly
recent where you can go actually we're
not talking about tofu and you know
actual meat cells grown in laboratories
so one of the aspects that I love about
this project is exactly that is that it
brings a number of experts from diverse
fields together around
a common project and the fact that it's
geographically that it's real it's we
can all collaborate on this in this one
place and this one spot for the same the
same goal I think is a great catalyst
for for change so on the food side I
would say that our aim is once we get
past the Python we get into bigger size
units that we would be completely
autonomous we have to figure out what do
we do for sugars you know are we going
to be growing beets or sugar cane to get
sugar the salt obviously we have no
problem we may have an excess of salt
water fresh water we're in a region that
that gets very well irrigated we get a
lot of rain so there's strategies where
all of the roofs all the roofs off the
sea studs would be used for catchment so
water catchment we have technologies
also that we're looking at very very
innovative brand new technologies
they're still in the lab for getting 4d
selling with Low Energy the big cost of
course is decel and the other issue is
brine you know if you have a large
concentration of very briny liquid what
do you do with it we cannot possibly
plant just let it you know put it back
into the lagoon it would sink and you
can literally create these pools of a
brine at the bottom of a lagoon which is
obviously unacceptable so we have to
figure out how to deal with all of these
cycles so on food there there's a lot of
work to be done we've talked to
companies that are doing vertical
farming with UV so they're saying okay
you've got limited space let's go
vertical so I mean we're talking to
companies that have containers that can
produce you know we've heard some
figures of a million pounds of food per
acre per year so very innovative stuff
it's UV lighting at the right wavelength
I've heard of some NASA micro you know
nanotech which you you spray on the
leaves of of whatever you're growing and
they create like micro prisms that
change the wavelength of the light to
match what the for me and just some
out-of-the-box this is stuff that NASA
has been using on I believe on the space
station things like that so the the
technology is out there I believe for us
to be able
to use the energy from the ocean and
nutrients and don't forget the oceans
are full of nutrients but we're not the
objective is not that we're just going
to be on board a sea stead eating fish
all the time I mean that's that's the
staple for Polynesians we've been doing
this for a thousand years now I assume
our guests and our friends international
friends would like more varied menu so
I'm sure we're gonna be looking at some
some innovations in the food space
[Music]
you